بعد ايه من قليله من تسممها مهام وزاره
الاتصالات العراقيه تقرر هيام الياسري حجب
المواقع الاباحيه على الانترنت الوزاره
اصدرت بيانا بشان هذا القرار لكن من دون
اي تفاصيل اخرى
[موسيقى]
القرار هو كحالي غيره اثار جدلا واسعا
البعض وجد الخطوه الشجاعه من امراه واخرون
يجدونه قرارا وصفوه بالفاشل بعض السياسيين
ايضا وبعض زعماء الكتل السياسيه ادلوا
بدلوهم بما يخص قرار بين الرضي والقبول
الرافدين للقرار يرون ان الحج لن يمنع
الشباب عن زيارتها هذه المواقع مع وجود
الشبكات الافتراضيه القادره على ازالتها
هذا الحجم ويجدون ان من اولويات الوزارات
تطوير خدمات الاتصالات المواطنين وخفضي
اسعار الانترنت وشبكات الهواتف المحموله
ومكافحه الفساد داخل مؤسسات الوزاره
المؤيدون للقرار هجمه كبيره ضد معارضيه
قالت الهجمه اعلاميه تعمل في احدى القنوات
العراقيه بعد ان غردت على حسابها في تويتر
قائله ايهما اهم اليوم حسب المواقع
الاباحيه ام يقرا رقانون لمكافحه العنف
الاسري
[موسيقى]
القرار جاء بعد ايام قليله لقرار وزاره
الاتصالات في حكومه اقليم كردستان بحضر
المواقع الاباحيه وسبق لبرلمان المركز ان
صوت لصالح قرار يلزم وزاره الاتصالات
العراقيه بحجم هذه المواقع الا انه لم
يفعل بشكل تام لتقرر الوزيره الجديده
تفعيله اليوم
[موسيقى]